Jody Chesney had no connection to gangs
we wasn't doing anything wrong we wasn't
bothering no and we didn't have no
arguments she was stabbed in the back as
she sat in a park with friends taken
away our lives basically ended as we
know it that night she died on her
father's birthday she popped to Atlanta
banisters happy birthday dad so cheers
darling go for a kiss I will have to
work she was later murdered that night
only one person attached Jody but two
young men were found guilty of killing
her drug dealer Swenson Olga cui and a
17 year old who can't be named because
of his age on the day of the killing
onic we met with another drug dealer
Manuel Petrovich at a cafe in Romford
their phones were their livelihoods drug
lines to reach hundreds of customers
linking both the men Jody hadn't known
them and they didn't know her as it
started to get dark she'd walked to the
park with friends the only link one of
the group had cancelled an order of
cannabis from among a cream and it
didn't turn up saying they'd order it
from another dealer instead we was
always taking stupid hoes and sending
each other shoe pateros Clarisse sharp
Jodi's close friend was there that night
everyone was laughing jokey listening to
music yeah then it just I don't know our
nowhere it just changed at 20 past 9:00
in the dark on the cui and the
seventeen-year-old were filmed walking
across to where Jodie and her friends
were Petrovich and the 16 year old had
dropped them off in his car and seconds
after Jody had been stabbed they raced
down the road to pick them up
I could see Jodie quickly turned and
then there was just screams and it was
very high-pitched in pain screams and
because it was so dark we couldn't see
we couldn't see what just happened
we couldn't properly see if the people
were still around if they'd left who
came and done it and I check her back
and there was just blood
one of our friends was started to scream
help please someone help none of us
really know what to do he was just
trying to make sure she stayed awake
obviously but that didn't happen but we
was trying not best Jodi never made it
to hospital a single stab wound 18
centimeters deep almost passed through
her body she was dead an hour later
detectives believe she was the innocent
victim in a drugs turf war as forensic
team swept the area to try to find her
killer
on work we returned to where he lived to
pick up fresh trainers he'd burnt the
clothes he wore that night
it is impossible to categorically say
who stabbed Jodi and in court on aquion
the 17 year old both blamed each other
the wound that Jodi suffered was
horrific and you can't do that sort of
thing without thinking that you're going
to kill someone will the family ever
find out why I don't think so
both were no strangers to violence this
was on acquis the September before
jumping off a motorbike to join in a
fight with two other boys the 17 year
old was also there he'd been following
in a car it's claimed he got out and
stabbed one of the boys in the neck I
won't tell you what I'm thinking looking
at that guy on the dock one side I want
to listen to what he's got to say for
himself and another side or a tears it
off
no we at most
someone
beautiful
and so is the world like it this was the
video Jodi's family played at her
funeral talented and kind a young life
needlessly cut short
[Music]
beautiful